au moment de l'explosion du 4 août rim à
jassem réfugiés syrienne de 33 ans à
envisager le pire
j'ai pensé que j'avais peut-être perdu
le bébé à cause de l'horreur de tout
cela deux ou trois jours plus tard je
suis allé voir le médecin et dieu merci
elle m'a dit que tout allait bien
finalement la petite ella a vu le jour
il ya environ deux semaines en bonne
santé mais la famille est traumatisé je
n'ai pas dormi depuis l'explosion
ça me revient constamment en tête et je
suis pétrifiés à l'idée qu'il y ait une
autre explosion
vous sentez que les choses ne sont pas
sur vous avez peur que quelque chose
arrive tout le liban se sont ainsi parmi
les milliers de beyrouth un sans
domicile depuis la catastrophe
l'onu a recensé 4600 femmes enceintes et
mis en place un programme dédié avec le
fonds des nations unies pour la
population créée en 1969
certaines femmes sont arrivés chez nous
avec un travail prématurée d'autres avec
des hémorragies
certaines étaient très traumatisée nous
les avons donc transporté chez des
personnes qui pouvait leur apporter un
soutien psychologique afin qu'elles
puissent surmonter le problème
nous avons fait des estimations basées
sur une équation
aujourd'hui nous savons que 300000
personnes ont été déplacés ont fui les
zones touchées par la double explosion
parmi ces trois cent mille personnes
nous estimons qu'il ya 84 mille femmes
de 15 à 45 ans donc en âge de procréer
l'onu distribuer des kits d'hygiène des
serviettes hygiéniques notamment
ressource précieuse dans le contexte
actuel avec la dépréciation de la livre
libanaise les prix explosent depuis le
drame
l'organisation a distribué 35 mille kits
de dignité
selon le terme usité